Dearest queen,
You are mad. Giving me a palace; It is a monstrous extravagance.
Mrs. Molly, we are at war.
We won.
Oh it is not over. You must continue.
Oh!
Oh, I did not know that.
The queen is an extraordinary person.
They were all staring weren't they? I can tell even if I can't see, and I heard the word fat. Fat.
And ugly.
No one but me would dare and I did not.
She's been stalked by tragedy.
Everyone leaves me.
He dies.
Aaahh!
I apologize for my appearance. I hoped I might be employed here, by you,
as something.
A monster for the children to play with, perhaps.
Grrrr!
It is important to make new friends in court, is it not?
You're so beautiful.
Stop it oh. You mock me.
If I were a man, I would ravish you.
You have become close to Abigail. She is a viper.
You're jealous
You'll send abigail away.
I do not want to.
Let's shoot something.
(gunshot)
Oh!
Sometimes it is hard to remember whether you have loaded the pellet or not
I must take control of my circumstance.
Throw.
I'm on my side. (gunshot)
Always.
Favor is a breeze that shifts direction all the time. Then in an instant, you're back sleeping with a bunch of scabrous whores
As it turns out, I'm capable of much unpleasantness.
Good use, look at me. Look at me!
How dare you! Close your eyes!
I could not just stand by and let you destroy me.
You are enjoying all of this, aren't you?
Oh it is fun to be queen sometimes.
If you do not go I will start kicking you, and I will not stop.
My dear friend, how good to see you've returned from-
hell. I'm sure you shall pass through it one day.
(scoffs)